Sam Smith fans out over fifth harmony  and it's official he's the cutest  [Music]  the singer teamed up with James Corden  for a new installment of carpool karaoke  and while the Grammy winner is a huge  star in his own right he admits he's  quote obsessed with bits harmony when I  hear them I feel free I feel you feel  free when you hear the three I feel  alive I feel like the woman in me it's  on fire work from home I listen to every  time before I go out I think my wedding  song Gordon and Smith busted out their  cover of the girl groups hit that's when  the late-night host  pulled over and surprised the 25 year  old in an epic way  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  if that were cute enough Smith and fifth  harmony jammed out together and he just  couldn't keep his cool oh my god I can't  believe that they were here first made  my year  [Music]  Oh